what up it's Lizzie Osama the trench
baby make sure y'all go check me out on
bootleg cast podcast you know how we
rock it
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here from Chicago
your new project just dropped so tons of
baby three trench baby three little say
Osama is in the building man welcome
welcome is this a new is this a
relatively new chain the trench baby
chain I probably got this like a year
ago not like nine months ago that's a
serious piece of ice right there let's
try this baby with the ski mask on and
the mist and the matching ring yeah
that's what's that I've never seen the
ring chain or something oh that's that's
Osama Bin Laden Osama lazee or something
okay uh how did you get your name man
uh let's get the mic right if you can
move the mic in front of you yeah
perfect yeah first at first they was
calling me like Zay Zay you know lizay
you know me being in the streets for a
long time you know they just thought oh
something oh something I guess it was
off the street [ __ ] you know yeah yeah
uh
how long has it been since you decided
to fully focus on music and get out of
the streets fully because a lot of
people do the one foot in one foot out
[ __ ] for real since I got out of jail
because you know I wouldn't did you in
our life and then when I got out you
feel amazing it's like yeah I gotta
focus on my craft you know I got to get
my people out the hood I got to get
myself together and that's really the
only lane I knew you know I wouldn't I I
know how to adapt to anything like
hustling fraud whatever you know what
I'm saying because like that wasn't what
I wanted to do I'm saying the music what
I wanted to do so yeah
yo you can't open the door okay you're
recording you're going there
you wanna water
boom
gotta hydrate gotta get the water man
um so you said that uh you obviously you
did some time in juvenile
what time do you get locked up you were
16
um when I was 15. 15 and then when did
you get out
when I was
I don't know I was 19 when I got up so
you did four years in between juvie so
when you got arrested did you go from
juvenile hall to like the adult [ __ ] no
I went from
um the Audi home which is uh doing a
correctional center and then I went from
the Audi home and got sentenced and then
I went to Doc Department of Corrections
a little doc you can't beat over 21
enough got you yeah so you ended up
doing time
as a juvenile and then all and then
moving on to the actual like being in
jail like people who are adults yeah so
that was like a something that kind of
shook you up obviously no hell no no I
was already used to it you know I was in
the streets I was going to do 30 days
then get out go do 60 days and get out
go do two months three or four months
get out you feel me I was always back
and forth locked up when I was a young
Just For Nothing when that real time
came it was like I was already used to
it for real damn what was your charge I
had an aggravated discharge of a firearm
uh I had a um armed robbery I had a um
vehicles I hijacking I had a couple a
lot of [ __ ] yeah four years worth of
[ __ ]
well you made it man you made it out you
made it out from the other side
I saw uh that you said that back in the
day you used to Rob all the cameramen in
Chicago come on man don't do that
I have my little ups and downs you know
I did my I did my little wrong [ __ ] I
was gonna say like um
did you ever spin the block on the
cameraman where they ended up working
with you later on
because you know there's there's only a
few cameramen I'm sure I mean I don't
know I don't even for real for real I
don't even remember all the dumb [ __ ] I
used to be on back then I was on
security [ __ ] but like
I used to be on some goofy [ __ ] like
that but I don't remember exactly all
the ones you know it probably is because
all the cameraman's [ __ ] them yeah you
know I am who I am today you know I
overcame all that [ __ ] so a lot of the
cameraman spoke with me it probably been
one of theirs I don't even remember
actually so long ago it feels like a
cameraman's probably the easiest lick
right
I was really I was it wasn't like I was
doing it for the money I was really
doing it to get my own camera to shoot
my own videos and how my my camera man
shoot my videos so you would Jack the
nice camera yeah give it to your camera
man and it'd be like you got no
equipment shoot my [ __ ] that's not a bad
uh I mean listen that's not bad at least
you weren't like at least there was a
some sort of purpose you were doing it
to further your career the thing I do is
for a purpose yeah it ain't never for no
reason 100 trench baby three you got
some dope features on here I swear Vezzo
was one of my favorite artists is on
there uh obviously hot dogs congrats to
him in the QC situation yeah for sure uh
obviously Derek herbo
um for you like this is technically is
this your first project like as like
under a major no hell no I did Hood
Bible I did trans baby one I was
wondering yeah yeah so this is okay so
you see this this her Bible I did Hood
Bible I did trans baby one trans baby
two and this trans baby three so four
makes safe since I've been under one so
is this considered a tape or uh that's a
mixtape okay yeah these days I hate I
hate the mixtape I was gonna say these
days how do you differentiate I feel
like a bootleg yeah but how do you
what's the album to the mixtape
difference like it feels like it's all
this [ __ ] same nowadays I don't know
that [ __ ] is kind of the same but I
don't like calling the mixtape because
they feel like I'm saying my [ __ ]
bootleg or some [ __ ] you know why I like
to call it a little project or
because the label doesn't count it
against your contract so they love it
when it's called a mixtape no not
necessarily most in most situations if
you recoup you know and that [ __ ] go go
to some [ __ ] and they're gonna count
that [ __ ] as an album yeah they have to
yeah yeah I think I'll count that I'm
gonna forget that album so uh do you
because I feel like your Buzz is like
really Catching Fire
um what do you think like uh
has been the difference in the last like
12 months or so since shit's really
Catching Fire for you in terms of just
like was it things you were doing
differently was it a certain record that
went crazy like why do you think like
you got the most eyes on you like right
now I feel like the momentum going crazy
right now you know what I'm saying
because my brother smirk hopped up on
the [ __ ] my cousin yeah he hopped on
that record so a lot of more people
reaching out and saying [ __ ] I hit
seeing a message like hey oh I ain't
even see this what up like you know like
everybody everything falling in place
since bro hopped on the record with me
yeah I feel like we always talk about
how people get the Drake stimulus
package yeah there's like a such thing
as a dirk stimulus package yeah so nine
days bro my daughter when Dirk is on a
record gang like
turn the nigga's career around like
folks hop on the record I mean we talked
about Vezzo he had up the score which I
feel like yeah really put him in a
different space hopped on that
[ __ ] took him out of the Boston
Rich he's Dirk on that yeah
blood golden in this [ __ ] he stamped
[ __ ] for sure 100
um for people who have never heard [ __ ]
my cousin oh yeah
the song titles wild right for sure
explain [ __ ] my cousin it was like I
just couldn't sugarcoat it you know
that's what it was you know I got a lot
of cousins that's on the other side with
the Ops so if you have a family member
who's on the other side with the Ops
[ __ ] them hell yeah [ __ ] them because
they don't think the same about you [ __ ]
you you up you know like of course
you're one like I ain't seen these
[ __ ] since I was
a kid you know what I'm saying but then
my cousins though you feel me so it
really ain't no relationship that anyway
you feel what I'm saying it's just that
we know we cousins you know and it's up
here on that side I'm on this side it
have been times I'd have gave my cousin
them passes like now folks don't do that
or not I was gonna keep it moving or
catch him he's so goofied out he's such
a [ __ ] clown catch him smack him up
punch him up put it on camera upload it
on the ground or something like just
treat him like a flat allegedly yeah
like [ __ ] like that like right
but hey yeah my homie you know she my
cousin I miss up I see my cousin is
there uh is there like a family like
okay because you could be you could be
cousins with somebody and barely know
them yeah for sure right that's that's
and that's that's normal that's what it
really is like with the cousins that I'm
a tool with okay you feel what I'm
saying like
I normally I grew up with them but it's
like ain't no bond or no relationship
death you know what I'm saying
for me to feel some type of way you have
a stronger bond with your brothers that
are yeah my brothers and my sisters like
I got real actual cousins that I know
that would never turn on me never go
[ __ ] with the Ops never do no out of
order [ __ ] across me you know I got
cousins like that that's my real family
right that you grew up with that you're
still close enough super super close to
it for sure damn does the Auntie ever
call like your mom and be like hey
yeah it have been times like that in the
past like
even one of my Ops that's dead like his
daddy is from well my mama and my daddy
know from well I grew up as a kid though
right and I'm moving over there but my
mom and him from over there that's where
they grew up at all their life 43rd
State Street you know like
and he he came and talked to me like
yeah y'all leave that [ __ ] alone y'all
family
you know but this [ __ ] too deep like
Bloodshed behind this [ __ ] already so
the [ __ ] really can't take that
[ __ ] back
I think that's what civilians have a
hard time wrapping their head around
why the cycle doesn't stop and I think
what they don't understand is once blood
is shed
it's like almost like I'm not talking
about you're I'm not talking about yeah
for the record though I will make it
clear I'm not talking about you or any
situation you're I just mean in terms of
gang violence in general yeah it's just
like bro you gotta understand bro if
if you kill me
I got kids I got little brothers I got
cousins that I don't want to get to get
back
boy they ain't gonna play about me they
ain't gonna forget about me boy right
it's gonna be generations and
generations of this [ __ ] you feel me
this [ __ ] go on I'm gonna go on like
generations for real for real like it's
not possible you took a [ __ ]
love one out this [ __ ] [ __ ]
already dude man I'm [ __ ] ready to go
all out you know did you see uh recently
21 Savage spoke about like in Atlanta
obviously there's a lot of gangbang or a
lot of gun violence happening did you
see what 21 Savage had said he just kind
of was trying to put a message out there
to everybody to like kind of you know I
think I saw a post when he was like we
we need to do better so yeah do better
try to keep the peace like do you think
like it would take somebody like in that
position to kind of like do the same
thing in Chicago or it doesn't matter
like
I mean I feel like
like I told you it's like we I know me
personally bro we was in Wars from
Generations ago that my big homie am I
older than them homie that was in you
feel what I'm saying and then it just it
just came down it just kind of gets
passed on so like that's that [ __ ] will
never be over with I don't care who you
is bro like that should never be over
with [ __ ] can't come to agreement and
come to each other and talk and be like
let's watch this [ __ ] or leave it alone
or uh or he gonna be considered a hoe he
gonna be considered a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] a
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] [ __ ] pride in the way
that [ __ ] ain't gonna never end it feels
like pride is probably the biggest uh
thing standing in the way in a lot of
that [ __ ] right yeah for sure but you
know like I told you deaf too
pride and death yeah [ __ ] got locked
up since the 80 years he told and he's
still out of jail [ __ ] been trying to
kill him like this [ __ ] it's all type of
situations do you think like um for
someone like yourself that has found a
way to get out of
that environment
is like the only right thing to do is to
kind of get out of Chicago and and try
hell yeah like I told you I'm in Atlanta
so you feel me let me think of Someone
Like Chief Keef I Don't Think Chief
Keef's been back for I don't know how
long but you know it feels like he got
about the world some light got them
snuck and never told nobody
no but for the most part though I don't
think you've been out there but hell
yeah like it's better to just get away
you know it's better just get the [ __ ]
out the city
you already got like I'm just saying me
I already got Ops hella Ops you feel
what I'm saying and there's money in
this [ __ ] Fame this [ __ ] bring
Mo enemies and more problems and
[ __ ] you feel what I'm saying so
that's just I don't so it's best to just
get the [ __ ] away get out your shitty
tuck off and run that [ __ ] up and take
care of people for real for real this
[ __ ] really dried up in the streets this
[ __ ] over with yeah I think that's smart
man hey what up it's bootleg cab we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
what our good friends at my bookie
football season has started my favorite
time of the year because I love to
gamble on football it makes watching
football so much fun it's my like
literally I just love watching football
and I love it even more when I got money
on the line and no matter where you are
right now what state what country you
can get in on the action it's a winning
season go to my bookie sign up for a new
account register and get that double
deposit bonus using the promo code
bootleg now let me tell you what that
means that means when you go to my
bookie let's say you make a 250 deposit
using the promo code bootleg you'll have
five hundred dollars to gamble with
that's right they're gonna double your
[ __ ] money right now they got the
prop builder you could bet on uh whether
or not I don't know well Matthew
Stafford throw for three touchdowns will
Kyler Murray rush for a touchdown you
could put all those on one thing and
secure the [ __ ] bag all right
get online with your boy let's get this
money together my bookie go sign up with
that promo code bootleg and double your
deposit right now go register help me
understand because you know so sometimes
I get frustrated
from the outside looking in when I see
people who have real beef with like real
people who are from their city like
situations that you were just talking
about
but then we'll beef with rappers that
aren't from their city and then that
equals [ __ ] and it's like almost like yo
like rap beef is so it's turning into
something very serious obviously people
have lost their lives in some of these
beasts but yeah because this [ __ ] ain't
this [ __ ] ain't back then like how
you'll see
like
you'll see like you'll see like 50 50 or
something Ja Rule or P Diddy like
they'll be like
on the internet going back and forth
arguing like but it's like you never see
nobody Dead behind it or you don't never
see it like go up for real for real so
[ __ ] on the outside from Speed
Street standpoint like man that [ __ ]
fake them [ __ ] doing that that's a
publicity stunning some [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying like like us nowadays
like
it ain't no faking like we don't know
how to fake we too real for this [ __ ]
like we don't know how to fake like if
it's up it's up we ain't gonna we ain't
gonna do no [ __ ] I'ma stop saying we me
I ain't gonna do no [ __ ] to hop on the
internet and be like I was up with him
was cracking with him and then we see
each other we shaking hands or we taking
a picture or a photo if I say it's up
it's really that you feel me but I got
that side of me I'll come to you and
talk like a man and get an understanding
you know what I'm saying if it ain't no
Bloodshed behind it or if it ain't
nothing serious yeah I feel like the rap
[ __ ] sometimes like it turns it starts
with something like extremely weird and
Petty and then sometimes it just gets
serious quick like it's like it goes
from like some weird internet [ __ ]
someone's on Instagram live saying some
passive aggressive shoes generation
different yeah this generation different
ah Temple's bad we're [ __ ] just ready
to go off the bridge I didn't give him
up yeah yeah it's it's like it's
unfortunate too man because it's like
I just see this [ __ ] too much I'm like I
gotta be a [ __ ] like me you gotta have
this head in this head yeah I got two
heads on myself what do you mean by that
what two heads on my shoulders yeah this
right here I can be this way right here
and I could be this way right here cause
I've heard the music it feels like you
know you got you got some pretty
aggressive records yeah
um
how was your did you have a relationship
with Vaughn before he passed yeah yeah
yeah me and Von used to always be in the
inbox tweaking with each other kicking
any [ __ ] like that me and bro was
supposed to do the record together but
blood was getting hot he was doing that
for sure he needed to do it and I was
doing the [ __ ] I needed to do you know
trying to figure my [ __ ] out but yeah
hell yeah blood was a cool ass down to
earth [ __ ] for sure for people who
don't know what uh what part of Chicago
are you from I'm from like the southwest
side 63rd California the kids that's
across West she's 300 how far is that
from because everyone knows obloc they
gotta it's on GTA now so like like I'm
on my hood is from 61st to 67.
California the kids okay so
like you'd be seeing the fans tweaking
under my [ __ ] like ah Zay from 63rd how
he doing the song with with dirt
like I'm from 63rd but I'm from 63rd off
the other side of Chicago they on the
east side I'm on the southwest side got
you you feel what I'm saying so all I
got to do is get on 63rd and California
and ride straight down
to um the east side and be being
o-blocked you feel me it's just like a
straight shot down straight shot like 15
minutes 20 minutes
yeah do you feel like uh
for you obviously
you know
having because I saw the OTF logo on the
back your track your track listen are
you like officially an OTF artist I know
you know you know Dirk that's my mentor
so
it's just like really blue it was just
trying to get behind me on some anything
I could do to help anything I could do
to help whatever you need we need to do
like I'm behind you 100 type [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying so
we partner up on a lot of stuff you know
what are some of the game that you know
he you know I think some people forget
how long Dirk's been at this blood I
always tell me like stay consistent like
stay in the studio whatever you got to
do go do that [ __ ] and then come back to
the studio stay consistent this is a new
artist say a day out here you feel what
I'm saying yeah you can't let them
forget about you you know yeah and
always be different don't never do these
[ __ ] do you be different yeah yeah
that's crazy you know I feel like he's
right I mean I think Dirk's
he went through a couple of areas of
music and a couple of Errors of his
career where he was like on Death Jam
they were trying to do blood got real
live years of experience in this [ __ ] on
a lot of levels for sure
uh let's talk about Chicago hip-hop who
would you put
on the Mount Rushmore of Chicago rap
that's four people we gotta put four
people I gotta put myself though no you
gotta excluding yourself I exclude
myself okay
we're gonna put Chief Keef okay
we're gonna put
juice real Chance the Rapper
and smirk and Dirk no Kanye
Kanye cool but I can't put Kanye up
there you put Connie over like that's
that's are you put a chance over Kanye
yeah like chance
I feel like it's ah era Kanye that's
fair you know what I'm saying that's
fair Kanye West that's y'all ever my
mama and daddy number you ain't gonna
catch me riding through the city off no
yay that's gonna lie but I [ __ ] with you
ain't music I [ __ ] with you that's a
person we both Geminis it's the most
[ __ ] like you know what I'm saying but
like why do you think that is like in
Chicago there's such a dynamic range of
artists that are like you got the
chances you got like the Vic Menses the
Kanye's the commons and then on the
other side you got the chief keeves the
Dirks guys like yourself like it's like
either like super artsy very like you
know heavily like art involves rap and
then there's like the hardcore gangster
[ __ ] like but but is it because they
grew up in different areas or I don't I
don't really know the history behind
like
all those people all those people like
that's coming and like all of them like
I don't I can't even tell you the street
comment grew up on for real like I don't
really know you ever listen to comment
probably when pops or somebody was
listening Chicago lady twister too yeah
yeah twister for so I went to the gun
range with twister and [ __ ] twister took
you to the gun range yeah Twisted took
me to the gun right into me and a lot of
my homies we were shooting guns and [ __ ]
he'd be showing us all the exclusive ass
guns he got and said all type of bit
crazy ass [ __ ] he's like training people
like how to get their gun permit and
yeah that's what that's what that's what
he gonna do with me that's fine shout
out to twister Twister's a great guy how
did he just reach out to you how did
that end up happening um I think we
supposed to have been doing a song or
some [ __ ] and then you know it was just
on some regular [ __ ] like it's beyond
the song type [ __ ] like let's just build
you know on some big brother bro [ __ ]
you know he's a good dude yeah for sure
shout out to say he's a [ __ ] Legend
shout out to Chicago man uh on [ __ ] my
cousin you're sad if you don't like the
[ __ ] Ops posts
uh if you like that if you like the Ops
post
so let me ask you this right
hypothetically speaking Yeah
you have like a relative that's close to
you yeah
and we're talking like in this song from
what I gather if you're cool with my Ops
or if I'm cool with you that means that
you can't you can't be [ __ ] with the
Ops
is that fair
yeah yeah like if I'm [ __ ] with you
and you [ __ ] with my Ops [ __ ]
you might back down me you might give me
smoke you might set me up Rob me I don't
know so if you're cool with somebody
trust you if you cool with somebody
that's trying to kill me or so let me
ask you this right so like
hypothetically speaking like you will
you inherit someone's beef that you're
[ __ ] with or would you just kind of
be like I I ain't beefing with him but
I'm not [ __ ] with them
no that's the type of [ __ ] I am I ain't
beefing with them but I'm not [ __ ]
with them that's what I'm saying
um
play both sides or right be in the
middle because I know being in the
middle lead
to a lot of other [ __ ] [ __ ] don't be
righteous [ __ ] really be like I'm in
the middle and really be over there
right plotting to come get your ass feel
myself I don't trust none of that [ __ ]
if you [ __ ] with them [ __ ] with them no
I ain't [ __ ] with you because I think
some people saw um
I think Rich the kid had dinner with
uh with Dirk but Rich the kid has an
album with a young boy so a lot of
people were like what the [ __ ] is going
on here right right I feel like I like
the young boy smirk [ __ ] like this this
is happening but I feel like a lot of
artists
on real time and if things just throwing
theyself you a [ __ ] ass goofy ass lame
ass [ __ ] if you just hop out there
throwing yourself with somebody beef you
don't really got in a relationship with
the [ __ ] you don't really nothing you
just dick ride it's almost like it's
like a a Some Cloud chasing [ __ ] little
kid yeah like like
that's just dick riding gang if you
hopping into another [ __ ] beef
they don't got nothing to do with you I
agree I just I agree I agree with you
yeah for sure I think like at the end of
the day like it's like I think that that
Dirk uh young boy thing is like one of
those things that like to me felt like
some rap [ __ ] and it was like okay yeah
obviously now see I knew it was no rap
[ __ ] folks like you gotta understand
like I don't know [ __ ] around Dirk I
know right personally like we've been
locked in for years since way before
this [ __ ] you feel what I'm saying like
I was even [ __ ] with a few of NBA and
all late homies over there yeah see what
I'm saying like but smirk numbers from
my city I've been locked in with them
for a long long time like it's real live
love with them like that you know what
I'm saying but I'm not out here oh [ __ ]
young boy right you're not jumping out
to do that that's what I mean that's
what I mean I think that's but I think
that's important that ain't me because I
think some people would do that and you
know how they'll be there see me on the
song with smirking all the fans like uh
[Music]
I think a lot of this [ __ ] too is like
fans push that [ __ ] dude yeah they they
they they push that [ __ ] I think like if
you think of what's going on with Kodak
and young boy right now it feels like
it's all fan the fans created some
[ __ ] between two artists that should
have no problems they're not from the
same section they're up from [ __ ] the
same state it's just some fan [ __ ] that
turns into some real [ __ ] or you know
some internet [ __ ] I guess but about
some questions though about Rich the kid
sitting in the room and [ __ ] like that I
don't really got no comment on it if he
one of them [ __ ] that's that's really
in the middle and don't got nothing yeah
I think like rich is obviously somebody
who was it was like a big dinner with a
lot of people and it's like he's looking
no [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] businessman we
don't get no [ __ ] in in that
environment in
you right here [ __ ] with the officer
you into a phone number was that is up
with you if you know what I'm saying so
phone numbers in the dinner with him so
I know they ain't feel no type of threat
or
he won he won't he couldn't have been on
[ __ ] to you know 100 gonna be sitting
there so
um
appreciate y'all watching but listen our
partners at Blue chew they got you
handled fellas and Etc whatever you are
they got it if you got a dick Bluetooth
is for you because they will make sure
your dick performs at all time levels I
mean like LeBron his first three seasons
with the heat type levels I mean your
wife will thank you for it everybody
will thank you for it [ __ ] even if you
just take a Bluetooth and jerk your dick
it's a it's a stronger jerk I swear to
God stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure you're
gonna be beating your dick like a stole
something so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg right now and you're gonna
get your first month free and this is
the great thing about Bluetooth the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discreet
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
thank me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the blue chew he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview you know when
you think of like
some of your peers and like how they've
evolved musically right think of Dirk
like Dirk's evolved musically in like a
level that's like crazy like
you know if you heard some [ __ ] from
nine years ago and you heard some [ __ ]
today it's like it's like night and day
like you know what I mean his Pen's gone
crazier the record's gone crazier what
are you doing like just on the artist
side to like push yourself when you're
in the studio are you [ __ ] working
with new producers like how's your
writing process are you taking things
you learned from other artists and
applying it to your craft like just in
terms of just improving the craft of
like your records and just as an artist
as an emcee like what are the things
that you're trying to always improve
um
I feel like I'm always trying to improve
like storytelling like
getting my words out better like putting
it together this happened this happened
that happened why this happened like I'm
that creative trying to put the songs
together like that for people to really
understand you know what I'm saying and
not just in my rap just like talking
about this thing and then go all the way
to this subject and that like [ __ ] be
jumping around and [ __ ] for sure
storytelling is important man yeah
what's some of your favorite like uh
storytelling records as a fan cause
there's been some great ones
[Music]
um
crazy story about King Von mm-hmm
what else I could say
one of my records called survive
who is this a storytelling [ __ ]
oh I think um Speaker Knockerz I think
okay what was that song he made back
then I can't even remember the song but
I think I [ __ ] it with my storage I
said there's a lot of [ __ ] I
just can't really think I'm talking
about you gotta listen there's a J's
which one
yeah
one bro and Meek Mill had one shout out
to me bro yeah I want to here's a Jay-Z
song
the next time you get a chance my mom's
a little Jay Z there's a Jay-Z record he
wanted bjz it's called Meet the Parents
yeah just listen to that record but
Focus I got a record called Meet the
Parents with another artist so the song
is about Jay-Z's rapping
uh from the perspective of three
different people a kid dies he gets shot
right so he's rapping from the
perspective of that kid he's right he
gets killed by his dad his dad doesn't
know it's his kid he's rapping from the
perspective of the dad and it's rapping
from his perspective of the Mom it's
[ __ ] crazy
but like every time you listen to it
you'll hear like a new like it's almost
like a Quentin Tarantino movie but on
record my favorite storytelling record
ever my suggestion just a little you
know an old head suggestion Jay-Z Meet
the Parents that'll step Your Story Each
Other yeah smoke you got more weed
we've got all this weed right no there's
definitely that's t-shirts I can get you
a pre-roll though grab a pre-roll out of
there no hell no I don't smoke Grabber
oh I mean this is a this is a raw paper
it's it's good for you I mean it's cool
you only smoke the grab a leaf
the thing about the leaf is like it's
such a process like you pull this
[ __ ] thing out of a bag I'll be
ripping that [ __ ] in two seconds
yeah I was in the studio the other day
with uh Tory Lanez and every time he
needed to [ __ ] roll something new and
just seeing him pull this [ __ ] Leaf
out and I'm just like they really stuff
a whole ass Leaf in a bag and then you
just find your the part you like and
then
I'm gonna tell you this like I don't
have any rolling uh talents and I can
only imagine the grab a leaf looks like
the hardest thing to roll
around here and that's actually easy
see that's why I like the bra yeah you
can roll to have the amount of weeds you
got you got some Louie well yeah because
it's a [ __ ] Leaf yeah you can just
cut what you need you cut what you need
yeah did you have you always smoked
Grava leaves yeah no I was I had my room
with back woods and I was smoking hella
Backwoods I can't [ __ ] with the
Backwoods yeah my runs with the Leafs
and all the smokers at least nah it's
just grab it but you were never smoking
papers though no I don't know papers you
know if you ever probably when I was a
young [ __ ] smoking leaves off the tree
and some more goofy [ __ ] all the big
like the big big smokers whiz burner
they only smoke papers
you [ __ ] a burner that's because they
probably getting old and said they don't
want to [ __ ] up their body right now
it's an old guy [ __ ] oh God [ __ ] they
getting older they ain't trying to be
around this [ __ ] losing their breath
all day it's good for you though yeah I
mean I don't know if it's good for you
let's say I get old I'm starting smoking
papers when I get older than 30. do they
do the uh spliffs in Chicago where you
get the tobacco and you put everybody's
smoke Backwoods everyone's on Backwoods
cheers
yo uh in terms of uh shout out to the
bulls the bulls had a little are you
like a basketball fan I'm a basketball
fan but ain't gonna lie I'm a Warriors
fan Stephen Curry and Klay Thompson my
favorite two players disgusting you're
funny I know but I go to the Bulls game
I support the boys they've only been
good for like six years the Warriors
it don't matter though like I was I
really got hooked to basketball in jail
I wouldn't know basketball watching ass
[ __ ] I was in jail on some boys when
the warriors were good and really got
hooked to the Warriors because they was
going so crazy I got the betting on
their ass in jail and everything
damn
yeah
this guy's from Chicago he's a Warriors
fan
hey I shout out to Buddha so you know
that home team
all right you got Alex Caruso you got a
I don't know nobody on the boards I knew
only [ __ ] I was [ __ ] with from the
Bulls was Wendell Carter but he traded
from him he got traded yeah you got
traded I think he's on the magic now I
told my boy we should have stayed at the
bus I don't think it was up to him he
got traded oh yeah yeah he got traded no
I don't know he's on the he's on the
magic now uh he's saying he was weak
Brody no I'm seriously with no car today
shout out to him yeah
uh how often do you go home
um like it's it's early on I just moved
to LA so it was really like I've been
from home sick [ __ ] I'm gonna go chill
with phone them I'm gonna go do other
[ __ ] I'll fly out just wake up in the
morning to be like come on were you able
to bring in your family with you yeah
that's important yeah for sure you got
your mom up out of there that's super
important man well my mama she ain't
come yet she hasn't come yet she'll be
saying I'm gonna leave Chicago get her
out of there man she got my grandma she
got to take care get both of them out of
there I've been telling them she said
she's scared to ride the plane
what you gotta send her a sprinter or
something yeah she she she took low
right now though but she definitely
gonna come out here I'm gonna make her
is she like out of the area at least
yeah different area yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're like because for people who don't
know like obviously Chicago is a very
segregated City it's probably one of the
more heavier set like segregated cities
in the country like there's
would you say so in terms of just like
this area is this area I had um Iman
Shumpert on and he was talking about
just how segregated it is I think
I mean I've been to a lot I don't know I
just I I'm from Iraq for real and I've
been everywhere in Iraq you know it's
probably been a lot a couple cities I
haven't been to Illinois but
like for the most part I feel like I see
black people everywhere right like
literally I don't give a [ __ ] if I'm in
this little ass town I'm gonna see at
least one black person no for sure for
sure for sure but for the most part it
probably is segregated because I go
somewhere and I see nothing but Mexicans
over here then I go so I see number
white people over here then you go over
here it's none of the black people and
probably a couple Mexicans stay on the
Block you know like [ __ ] like I heard
they have decent Mexican food in Chicago
because there is a big there is I'm from
a Mexican like area they don't got the
best relax you're in California oh tacos
whack yourself where did you go
I want the pink taco I went to
[ __ ] that's your [ __ ]
problem look look hey Taco is white
people taco all right listen let me tell
you I went to
no that was Mexican food I mean you have
to I went to a couple spots where they
had tacos was it a truck was it a truck
I did the truck before too but that it
wasn't only the truck though you have to
go to Leo's taco truck
Leo's taco truck I don't like eating at
the trucks I feel like I'll be getting
sick or maybe it's just a mad thing it's
a mind thing
you can't bring a pink taco though that
[ __ ] was so weakness God awful but Pink
Taco is [ __ ] white it's a white
person owned establishment I'm assistant
that's when I first got down the first
time me ever coming to L.A when I got
signed the one in 2019. hmm I'm trying
to find another city to eat I can't find
it nah since since then I've been out
here 100 times and I still no no no no
no no I got to get you right NoHo Pizza
got the good wings that's it
like I don't really y'all look
drive-throughs like all others you gotta
tap in man yeah I gotta are you in the
valley
you're like over this way yeah there's
great come on literally just drive
around North Hollywood oh Chef Grizzlies
let's look at that nah I don't know what
that is there's some black people [ __ ]
Chef Grizzlies fire
macaroni steak
I'm not mad at that I like macaroni and
steaks not black people so a lot of
people I love soul food you ever have
concrete not like that one I said black
people
who wasn't on the album I saw herbo
Vezzo Derek who else uh Vezzo PG Avenue
a little dirt Fredo bang shout out to
Fredo he's a great guy yeah that's my
boy very very a nice dude man uh what's
your favorite song on the album oh Lord
all of them hell yeah all of them I feel
like I overdid this one and I feel like
this one's the hardest I really brought
that Zay back for their ass yeah they
ass the pain yeah that's the drill do
you feel like the fans are um I feel
like they're satisfied I was gonna say
are they giving you that same feedback
like giving me that feedback bro you
went crazy that's one of the best albums
we want some more all right let me ask
you thinking about doing Deluxe I don't
know yet though you got to do the deluxe
I feel like it's kind of the thing to do
know yeah because you got you had did
you feel like I'm gonna just go ghost
real quick and then come back and drop
it out I was gonna say when you do uh
Deluxe usually it's like you have three
or four songs that you wanted to put on
the album didn't make the album and it's
easy to just throw them on it do you
have those records in mind I got 100
songs that they make the album that I
wish would have made though it's crazy
because so many artists have that right
where they have all these records that
will never [ __ ] hear you know what
I'm saying what do you want like like
when you cut a record do you pretty much
know within like a day whether or not
it's like worth releasing yeah yeah I
know right then and they're like yeah
this one once yeah well I see everybody
vibe in the studio and you'll know you
know I know otherwise you kind of look
at like the recording process because if
you're recording that much you know a
lot of the [ __ ] ain't gonna come out
it's kind of like working out like the
way somebody will go practice
likes it if it don't come out with this
it's going to come out with that oil you
know I feel like everything gonna get
used this is timing yeah
I make a lot of type of different music
if you just tell me you're talking
earlier about uh juice World juice World
obviously one of them ones uh Gone Too
Soon
uh the first thing to take me to the
chain smokers house you went to The
Chainsmokers crib yeah they asked for
spraying me water guns and see where I
was asleep I woke up I mean y'all last
tweaking boy [ __ ] is y'all doing what's
that what's that first of all tell us
this story how did you end up with juice
roll going to The Chainsmokers house
because I was in a Mystic
um I was like um lady was shopping and
[ __ ] like that right it like had a lot
of deals on the table and [ __ ] and I
went to Lincoln with my boy G money and
bibbing them because they were still
inside me and [ __ ] and uh they flew me
to L.A and I I went to their crib and
[ __ ] I was out there for them with them
for a couple days and [ __ ] and me and
Juice was chilling juice took me to the
studio
um Young Thug and then we left the
studio for one Young Thug and tank guy
then we went to the chain Smoker's crib
and bro we got there they were sitting
up in that [ __ ] just chopping
it up and [ __ ] talking about let's go
play laser tag and all type of [ __ ] they
was tweaking I fell asleep knocked out
in that [ __ ] they were sprinting water
guns while I sleep I wake up man y'all
ass tweaking boy y'all white boys
brother smack the [ __ ] out of him yeah
white boy humor is different man yeah
you hang out with enough white people
you get immune to some uh interesting
humans nah but I I love white guys
I got a couple of white friends couple
Mexican friends just a couple is all you
need you know what I mean
how was so you and Juice real pretty
tight yeah yeah we was good we was
getting tight I ain't gonna like like
you know I was gonna need here wake up
and be like come on say let's go ride
the dirt bike so let's go play the Xbox
folks was like he was grown but he was
like always on some activity kid [ __ ]
right all right you know folks yeah he
was young man that's what people forget
like he was such a prolific artist but
he was barely got to live a lot of his
life you know what I'm saying yeah he
was on some young kids [ __ ] too though
we gotta stop the interview tell you
about our partners at Odd Socks well
first of all let check out the brand new
collab
look at these the bootleg Kev sock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look oddstock's the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been rocking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by Odd
Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
when you see I would say when you see a
guy like Bibby who was able to like
successfully transition from being a
amazing artist into
big CEO [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
does that is that something that
inspires you that you kind of aspire to
try to get to eventually like where you
can sign artists you could kind of be
there yeah yeah I want to get to that
point really I want to rap get real real
real real real Rich to that point where
I can just really like sit back and like
spend time with my kids spend time with
my family in real real life live life
without and then let other people put
out loud yeah like I want to sit on my
ass and I M's coming in you feel that's
that's the way to go man are you doing
anything like that like in terms of like
the money you're making are you
reinvesting in it or like yeah for sure
what are you doing
it ain't no real live like crazy [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] it's just some minor right
now that's good stay out that crypto man
the cryptos they're full of [ __ ] with
the crimson you're gonna end up like the
guy on the couch over there he put all
his money in crypto look at him
you're straight no you're not not off
the how much money you got left out of
that [ __ ] money you put in your
[ __ ] crypto you got about 10 cents
left that's what you got that [ __ ]
crashed come on come on take this 300K
and come drop into your [ __ ] man give
you one percent back well listen uh your
project is out right now for sure go run
that [ __ ] up anymore this baby three out
right now man make sure y'all go run
that [ __ ] up on all platforms trans baby
serious is out right now my YouTube
Blizzard or something make sure y'all go
watch the series man more videos coming
more videos coming for the show for show
for sure I'll probably be getting
friends with babies full sooner than
y'all think or the deluxe so this is not
gonna be a Trilogy you're gonna keep
them going I'm gonna keep him going I'm
gonna be like Wayne with this [ __ ] what
Wayne on him well Carter Five is out and
he's he just announced Carter six he
moving slow yeah I've been on trans baby
team right now yeah yeah I don't know
the last couple quarters I was not crazy
about the last one I loved was Carter
three and I have a little one though he
was one one of them dudes he got this
were you in like let me ask you this
because you're kind of like the age
bracket oh
I was influenced because I feel like
nowadays like really her auto-tune from
like Wayne for real dude I'd be like
yeah because nowadays the generation of
young rappers coming up I feel like
we're more influenced by Like Chief Keef
or future or Thug yeah I'm I'm
influenced by blood in them too you know
but like Wayne before blood
yeah free YSL there it is man appreciate
you pulling up yeah I already know man
go get the album